K
PAPERWORK.
NICK PATON WALSH WITH THE
LATEST.
>> AMERICA'S FINAL ACT IN
AFGHANISTAN.
LONGEST WAR, AND IT INVOLVES
GETTING MANY AMERICANS, MANY
AFGHANS LOYAL TO AMERICA TO RUN
A KIND OF GAUNTLET FROM THE
CENTER OF KABUL UP TO THE MAIN
AIRPORT, WHERE THEY HOPE TO GET
FLIGHTS TO THE UNITED STATES,
MAYBE ELSEWHERE, AND START A
NEW LIFE IN SAFETY.
FOR THAT, THEY MUST GO THROUGH
AN EXTRAORDINARY CHALLENGE.
>> WHAT SHOULD BE THE EASIEST
DRIVE IN KABUL IS THE REASON
THE CITY IS ON EDGE.
HEAD UP THE MAIN AIRPORT ROAD
SINCE MONDAY WHEN I DROVE IT
WHEN YOU RUN INTO THE TALIBAN,
THEN THEY WERE BEATING PEOPLE
BACK, PERHAPS TO CLEAR THE
CIVILIAN RUNWAY CROWDED WITH
DESPERATE PEOPLE THEN.
BY WEDNESDAY, IT HAD GOTTEN
WORSE WHEN THEY WERE CLEARLY
STOPPING PEOPLE FROM USING
THEIR ESCAPE TO AMERICA, AND
ACCOSTING CNN.
TALIBAN CONTROL THAT ROAD THE
ENTRANCE AT THE END OF IT AND
THE ROAD TO THE LEFT.
NOW MANY ARE TRYING TO GET IN
FROM THE NORTH ROAD BUT THAT
HAS LED TO DEVASTATING SCENES
AT THE NORTH GATE.
WHEN I WAS THERE THE CRUSH WAS
DANGEROUS AND THE NUMBERS JUST
GROWING FURTHER STILL.
AT NIGHT STUN GRENADES HAVE
BEEN THROWN WHEN HUGE CROWDS
STILL BRAVE ROAMING TALIBAN IN
THE DARK, IN THE HOPE THE
NUMBERS AT THE GATE HAVE
DROPPED.
IN THE DAY IT GOT NASTIER
STILL.
THERE WERE MOMENTS OF HOPE BUT
THEY CARRY RISK -- WHEN PEOPLE
SEE ONE SUCCESS THEY MIGHT WANT
TO TRY THE SAME THING EN MASSE.
LATER IN THE DAY, BECAUSE
TROOPS HAD TO REPEL THE CROWD.
ANOTHER GATEWAY SEEMS TO BE
BRITISH SOLDIERS STRUGGLED TO
PUSH BACK CROWDS AND HUGE
QUEUES ARE FORMED BLOCKING THE
STREETS.
AMERICA HAS A NUMBERS PROBLEM
GETTING ENOUGH PEOPLE ON.
BUT ALSO CLAIMING HUGE PROGRESS
WHILE NOT REALLY KNOWING HOW
MANY PRIORITY CASES THEY ARE
REALLY SEEKING.
>> HOW AMERICAN CITIZENS REMAIN
IN AFGHANISTAN?
>> I DON'T KNOW.
>> WE KNOW 6000 PEOPLE ARE NOW
AT THE AIRPORT, 6000 PEOPLE
HAVE BEEN ABLE TO MAKE IT HAVE
MADE IT THROUGH THE PROCESSING
AND AS OF A COUPLE HOURS AGO,
WE RECEIVED ONLY A SMALL
HANDFUL OF REPORTS OTHERWISE
FROM THE AMERICANS.
>> INSIDE, IT IS MESSY.
THERE ARE FLIGHTS OFTEN MANY OF
THEM WHERE LIVES ARE WALKED
ONTO C17S AND CHANGED FOREVER
WHEN THE DOORS CLOSE.
THE STORY OF THE AIRPORT THE
LAST PLACE AMERICA CONTROLS IN
AFGHANISTAN WHERE THE CHAOS
OUTSIDE THE WIRE MEANS THE
PROMISES INSIDE FALL PERILOUSLY
SHORT.
THE U.S. TALKED OF LOFTY GOALS
OF TRYING TO GET 5 TO 9000
PEOPLE FLOWN OUT EVERY DAY, AND
THEY CLAIMED THAT THEY HAVE NOW
ON THEIR AIRPORT 6000 PEOPLE
PROCESSED AND READY TO GET ON
AIRCRAFT.
THAT WILL BE EXTRAORDINARY IF
THAT HAD INDEED OCCURRED.
THEY ALSO ADMIT AS YOU HEARD
THERE THAT THEY DON'T KNOW HOW
MANY AMERICANS ARE OUT THERE IN
AFGHANISTAN, HOPING TO GET OUT.
EXTRAORDINARY NOT TO HAVE THAT
BASIC NUMBER THERE TO QUANTIFY
HOW BIG A TASK IS AHEAD.
SO, FOR THE DAYS AHEAD, THERE
ARE CONCERNS THAT ONCE AGAIN IN
AFGHANISTAN THE REALITY OF THE
GROUND THOSE TERRIFYING SCENES
OUTSIDE THE AIRPORT EVEN TODAY
ARE SIMPLY NOT MATCHED OR
RECOGNIZED BY THE STATEMENTS
FROM AMERICAN OFFICIALS.
NICK PATON WALSH, CNN, DOHA.
MANY AFGHANS WHO MANAGED TO
BOARD A FLIGHT ARE FACING
UNCERTAIN FUTURES, SOME HAVE NO
IDEA WHERE THEY WILL ACTUALLY
END UP.
GOVERNMENTS WORLDWIDE STILL
FINALIZING DETAILS ON WHICH
COUNTRIES WILL HOST REFUGEES.
NATO FOREIGN MINISTERS WILL
MEET IN THE COMING HOURS TO
ADDRESS THE CRISIS.
WELL WE KNOW NOW IS THAT THE
U.S. SAYS IT WILL TAKE IN
30,000 AFGHANS.
THE UK AND CANADA 20,000 EACH.
MEANWHILE, TURKEY'S PRESIDENT
IS CALLING EU LEADERS TO TAKE
MORE RESPONSIBILITY, SAYING HIS
COUNTRY WILL NOT BE EUROPE'S
REFUGEE WAREHOUSE.
WAVES OF AFGHAN EVACUATIONS
POURING INTO DUBAI'S
INTERNATIONAL AIRPORT ON
MILITARY PLANES.
THE UAE HAS BECOME AN
EVACUATION HUB AND THE FIRST
STOP FOR MANY AS PEOPLE BEGIN
THEIR LIVES IN NEW LANDS.
CNN'S ELENI GIOKOS IS HERE WITH
MORE.
THIS ROYAL AIR FORCE AIRCRAFT,
CARRYING PASSENGERS FROM KABUL
LANDING HERE IN DUBAI WORLD
SCENT NOW ACCORDING TO
OFFICIALS, AROUND 1600 EVACUEES
FROM AFGHANISTAN.
THESE ARE ELIGIBLE AFGHANS WITH
PAPERWORK AND VISAS, AS WELL AS
BRITISH CITIZENS WHO HAVE BEEN
EVACUATED OVER THE LAST 4 DAYS
AND COMING HERE TO THE UAE.
UPON ARRIVAL, THESE PEOPLE,
PASSENGERS, ARE GIVEN MEDICAL
ASSISTANCE.
TESTED FOR COVID AND GIVEN, OF
COURSE FOOD, AND MUCH-NEEDED
WATER.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE EXPRESSION
ON THE PASSENGER'S FACES, YOU
SEE ALMOST PAIN AND NUMBNESS
AND A SENSE OF TRAUMA.
ONE NEEDS TO REFLECT ON THE
CHAOTIC SCENES AROUND KABUL
AIRPORT.
JUST GETTING TO THE AIRPORT WAS
A HERCULEAN TASK.
TRYING TO GET THROUGH THOSE
TALIBAN CHECKPOINTS AND TRYING
TO GET THROUGH THE AIR POINT
CHECKPOINTS TO FINALLY GET ON
AIRCRAFT LEAVING KABUL AND COME
TO AN AIRPORT LIKE THIS, WHERE
YOU ARE SEEING ASSISTANTS ALL
AROUND.
SOME PEOPLE CARRYING JUST
PLASTIC BAGS WITH THEIR
BELONGINGS, SOME JUST CARRYING
GARBAGE BAGS.
OTHERS BEING ABLE TO TAKE SOME
OF THEIR BELONGINGS, AND WE ARE
SEEING LUGGAGE BEING CARRIED
OUT.
YOU'VE GOT TO REMEMBER, THIS IS
A MILITARY AIRCRAFT.
THIS WASN'T MADE TO HANDLE
PASSENGERS.
YOU, KNOW FOR A LONG FLIGHT.
SO, YOU CAN ONLY IMAGINE WHAT
THE EXPERIENCE MUST BE LIKE.
THE ONLY SEMBLANCE OF HOPE I
CAN SAY, AND JUST NORMALCY I'VE
SEEN, AS WHEN YOU SEE TODDLERS
AND CHILDREN THAT ARE
ACCOMPANYING THESE VERY
TRAUMATIZED ADULTS, RUNNING
AROUND, AND PLAYING, AND
SMILING, AND IT KIND OF GIVES
YOU A SENSE THESE PEOPLE
ESCAPED A VERY HOPELESS
SITUATION.
ELENI GIOKOS, CNN, DUBAI.
>> NOW THE U.S. SAYS IT IS
WORKING OVERTIME TO APPROVE A
SPECIAL IMMIGRANT VISAS FOR THE
AFGHANS FLEEING THE TALIBAN.
A HOMELAND SECURITY OFFICIAL
SAYS IT IS ALL HANDS ON DECK
SITUATION.
BUT THE VISA PROGRAM IS SAID TO
BE BOGGED DOWN BY SYSTEMIC
ISSUES, BUREAUCRACY.
ONE U.S. OFFICIAL TOLD CNN THAT
THE SPECIAL IMMIGRANT VISA
PROCESS IS VERY SLOW BUT THERE
HAS BEEN VERY LITTLE ATTENTION
TO FIX IT.
THE PROGRAM BEGAN IN 2009 FOR
AFGHAN CITIZENS AND THEIR
FAMILIES WHO WORKED FOR THE
U.S. GOVERNMENT.
MEANWHILE, MEXICO HAS STARTED
PROCESSING REFUGEE ASYLUM
APPLICATIONS ON WEDNESDAY.
MEXICO HAS NOT SAID HOW MANY
REFUGEES HAVE PLANS TO ACCEPT.
OUR CORRESPONDENT IS LIVE FROM
ISTANBUL WITH MORE.
LET'S START WITH WHAT IS A MESS
AT THE AIRPORT.
AND NOW YOU'VE GOT THE U.S.
NEGOTIATING WITH THE VICTOR,
THE TALIBAN, TO GET SAFE
PASSAGE JUST TO GET TO THE
AIRPORT, LET ALONE GET IN.
IT'S BIZARRE, REALLY.
>> IT'S QUITE STUNNING, MICHAEL,
TO SEE THE U.S. GOVERNMENT AND
MILITARY HAVING TO NEGOTIATE
WITH THE TALIBAN, HAVING TO
RELY ON THEY ARE SURE INSTANCES
TO BE ABLE TO RUN THIS
OPERATION, TO KEEP IT GOING.
WE UNDERSTAND FROM U.S.
OFFICIALS THAT WE HAVE CHANNELS
OPEN WITH THE TALIBAN, THEY ARE
IN CONSTANT CONTACT WITH THEM,
TO CONTINUE THAT THE AIRPORT
CONTINUES THE EVACUATIONS.
WE UNDERSTAND THAT IT IS THE
TOP U.S. COMMANDER ON THE
GROUND LEADING THE
NEGOTIATIONS.
HE IS TALKING TO WHAT HE CALLS
HIS TALIBAN COUNTERPARTS.
BUT ONE ISSUE THAT THE U.S. HAS
BEEN FACING, THAT THEY HAVE
THESE NEGOTIATIONS OPEN, AND
YES SOME OF ACCUSATION FLIGHTS
ARE TAKING PLACE.
ONE OF THE ISSUES HAS BEEN THAT
THEY DON'T REALLY STILL, TO
THIS MOMENT THE STRUCTURE WHEN
IT COMES TO THE TALIBAN, WHO IS
CONTROLLING WHAT.
AND WHAT IS BEING NEGOTIATED
BETWEEN THESE COMMANDERS,
WHETHER THAT IS BEING
COMMUNICATED DOWN TO THE
FIGHTERS CONTROLLING THE
CHECKPOINTS, WHO ARE
CONTROLLING THE STREETS.
AND THIS IS PERHAPS ONE OF THE
REASONS WE ARE SEEING WHAT WE
ARE SEEING, FROM OUR TEAM ON
THE GROUND, THE REPORTS OF
PEOPLE FACING THESE OBSTACLES
OF HARASSMENT, BEATINGS IN
THEIR ATTEMPTS TO GET TO THE
AIRPORT.
AND MANY REPORTS OF PEOPLE
BEING BLOCKED BY THE TALIBAN.
OBVIOUSLY, MICHAEL, AFTER WHAT
HAS BEEN DESCRIBED AS THIS
CATASTROPHIC OPERATION, AND
THIS EVACUATION AT THE AIRPORT,
U.S. OFFICIALS ARE REALLY
TRYING HARD TO PROTECT PROJECT
THIS IMAGE THAT THINGS ARE
UNDER CONTROL AND THAT THINGS
ARE STARTING TO RUN SMOOTHLY.
THAT IS THE MESSAGING WE ARE
SEEING FROM D.C. OVER THE PAST
COUPLE OF DAYS.
OF COURSE, THE REALITY ON THE
GROUND IS VERY DIFFERENT.
WE HAVE TO SEE WHETHER IT IS
LIKE TODAY.
BUT WE UNDERSTAND, A SHORT TIME
AGO, A WHITE HOUSE OFFICIAL
ANNOUNCING THAT THEY HAVE
MANAGED TO GET 3000 PEOPLE
EVACUATED ON THURSDAY.
HE SAYS THAT THAT INCLUDES 350
U.S. CITIZENS, THERE'S ALSO
FAMILY MEMBERS, APPLICANTS FOR
THE SPECIAL IMMIGRANT VISAS AND
THEIR FAMILIES, AND OTHER
VULNERABLE AFGHANS.
THEY WERE ON 16 C-17 PLANES
OVER AFGHANISTAN, AND THE U.S.
MANAGED, THEY SAY, TO ARRANGE
11 OTHER CHARTER FLIGHTS.
BUT MICHAEL, AS YOU HAVE BEEN
DISCUSSING WITH YOUR GUESTS,
GETTING TO THE AIRPORT IS JUST
ONE OF THOSE CHALLENGES.
GETTING PEOPLE ON THESE FLIGHTS
IS JUST ONE PART OF GETTING OUT
OF THE COUNTRY.
YOU'VE GOT THAT VERY, VERY
DANGEROUS JOURNEY OF TRYING TO
GET TO THE AIRPORT, WHERE
PEOPLE ARE FACING THE
CHALLENGES.
U.S. OFFICIALS HAVE MADE IT